alexis foule un bonjour
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver dans
la matinale de rtl france alors l'été à
été marqué par les mesures de contrôle
sanitaire emmanuel macron n'a pas assuré
les français les manifestations
continuaient est-ce que la rentrée de
l'exécutif risque d'être sous tension
selon ben
oui clairement malgré les sondages du
jdd avec l'ifop qui montre une cote de
popularité en hausse honda je trouve pas
de complaisance on voit bien que
emmanuel macron aura du mal à calmer la
rue d'ailleurs il a évité le
traditionnel bain de foule qu'il faisait
à brégançon cette année il a simplement
fait des annonces lors des cérémonies du
débarquement sur les droits et les
devoirs des français et on peut se
demander comment il va se sortir de
cette confrontation avec la grogne qui
continuent contre cette vaccination
obligatoire qui ne porte pas son nom
puisque 100 passes sanitaire est bien
celle emplois qui disparaissent et
l'accès bien sûr au restaurant et un
plein de commerces on voit bien qu'il
n'a pas rassuré la vaccination
d'ailleurs est sur un plateau les
français se font davantage tester mais
pas davantage vacciner même si
l'objectif des 50 % de 50 millions
pardon de français vaccinés est toujours
d'actualité pour fin août on voit bien
que cette stratégie de la contrainte
voulue par les vacances et stratégies du
bras de fer avec la rue aussi est une
impasse une impasse sanitaire puisque
dans le pastel iter beaucoup de
questions restent en suspens sur le but
sanitaires un réel de ce pass qui
divisent les français on voit bien que
dans ces manifestations où les gens
restent nombreux y compris en août 1 au
coeur des vacances des français il y a
des gens vaccinés contre ces mesures
d'exception qui font une différence
entre citoyens et même à qu'on n'a pas
répondu à cette question là et on reste
dans le flou total quant à la rentrée
comment va être préparé la suite
l'assèchement bien sûr de ce pass
sanitaires à partir de novembre
puisqu'il est censé disparaître au 15
novembre si on en croit l'exécutif et
avec si l'objectif vaccinale est ce
qu'il est atteint et qu'attendre de ces
mobilisations anti passe
alors l'objectif vaccinale oui pour eva
les maquereaux il est atteint il a fait
d'ailleurs cet été des vidéos tik tok
depuis le fort de brégançon pour parler
aux plus jeunes à qui sont les plus
poreux à la propagande de l'exécutif
donc il va pouvoir aligner des chiffres
mais vacciner des populations qui ne
sont pas les plus à risque d'aller aux
urgences et de finir avec des formes
graves de covile ce n'est pas forcément
une bonne solution ça permet à mu et le
maquereau d'aligner des bons chiffres
c'est ce qu'il fait le mieux à des
projections des courbes des chiffres
mais la réalité c'est que certains
publics n'ont pas été touchés par la
vaccination encore et reste à risque et
puis il y a eu aussi le comme je le
disais le pas marqué dans la campagne
vaccinale avec des gens qui préfèrent se
faire tester plutôt que se faire
vacciner donc on continue à tourner en
rond un an après depuis mars on a vu
tout et son contraire emmanuel macron
rappelez vous devez faire un tour de
france sans prendre son bâton de pèlerin
et avoir plusieurs étapes comme ça dans
le pays il a arrêté rapidement après
avoir été giflé leur route de ces étapes
et puis il s'est enfermé au fort de
brégançon après ces annonces du 12
juillet qui forçait les français à la
vaccination qui les contraignait sans le
dire et puis ensuite depuis la polynésie
il a à nouveau fustigé ces français qui
ne comprenaient rien et maintenant on
voit bien que les crises s'amoncellent à
la rentrée économique risque d'être
délicate il ya maintenant la crise
afghane qui s'ajoute à la crise
sanitaire et on ne voit pas quels vont
être les réponses claires à porter par
l'exécutif et alexis concernant la
rentrée des classes à ce qu'elle a été
selon vous correctement préparé jean
michel blanquer lui se veut rassurant
comme d'habitude d'ailleurs c'était
frappant vous aviez la une du jdd 2 août
2020 et celle de août 2021 même photo
avec une barbe de plus pour jean michel
blanquer même message rassurant tout est
préparé tout va bien ne vous inquiétez
pas pas de vaccination pas de passes
sanitaires pour les professeurs ni les
élèves or les scientifiques alertent en
disant qu'avec le delta tout a changé ce
protocole sanitaire il n'a pas été
transmis aux personnels enseignants ni
aux personnels de direction il est
simplement est allé comme de la com
c'est ce que fait jean michel blanquer
depuis qu'il était au poste de ministre
de l'éducation nationale donc on a
l'impression d'une un prix paration
encore total on voit en israël que les
enfants se sont testés pour savoir s'ils
ont les anticorps s'ils ont déjà eu des
formes asymptomatiques du coc vite pour
éviter qu'il soit mis à l'écart en cas
de cas contacts ou autre en france
aucune campagne sur la sérologie des
plus jeunes mais par contre on va faire
des écoles des vaccinodromes à avec les
infirmières scolaires qui vont être
forts obligé de vacciner ou qui vont
inciter à la vaccination alors même que
certains enfants n'auraient pas besoin
de cette vaccination donc on voit bien
extend rassure ni les parents ni les
personnels enseignants et que le risque
c'est bien de retomber dans les travers
de 2020 c'est à dire une explosion
virale pour octobre parce que la rentrée
n'a pas été préparé par jean michel
blanquer qui fait de la communication il
y aussi la campagne présidentielle qui
va s'accélérer est ce que manuel macron
pour rester maîtres des horloges 1 comme
il aime à le penser
alors oui si on en croit les universités
d'été classique des partis classiques
emmanuel macron là peut jouer sa carte
c'est à dire continuer à diviser et à
droite et à gauche et a rassemblé de
nouveaux soutiens comme par exemple
françois rebsamen le maire de dijon qui
commence à demi mot à dire que le ps est
mort et que maintenant il va falloir
faire quelque chose avec la république
en marche ou du moins ce qui sera la
suite de la carrière politique des
malades macron donc s'ils jouent le jeu
classique des parties il peut
effectivement continuer sur un thème de
division et de rassemblement de
politique politicienne mais on voit bien
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses extrêmement
volatile il ya le mouvement bien sûr
contre le placent sanitaire qui agrège
de nombreux mécontents de la politique
des mâles macron de tous bords
politiques des gens qui manifestent pour
la première fois dans leur vie et il
pourrait y avoir la création d'un
nouveau mouvement politique issue de ces
manifestations il ya aussi des
candidatures originales comme celle
d'eric zemmour qui va servir à venelles
macron puisque les voix qui irait à eric
zemmour vont permettre d' affaiblir
marine le pen qui elle était au 2e tour
en 2010 est face à lui et puis il ya
toutes les inconnues bien sûr des
nouveaux candidats qui vont se présenter
et puis cette gestion sanitaire dans
laquelle emmanuel macron semblent
empêtrés s'il ne réussit pas à s'en
sortir alors il n'aura aucune chance
pour une réélection 2022 merci beaucoup
alexis l'édito d'alexis poulin a
retrouvé bien évidemment sur les réseaux
sociaux et on vous retrouve un lundi
prochain dans la matinale merci alexis